these on-screen romances were full of
chemistry
and seemed exciting until we realized
the major age differences from 30-year
age gaps to underage teens playing love
interest
these relationships came across as
normal in films and tv
we were shocked when we realized zendaya
has had not one
but two huge age gaps with romantic
co-stars
we're taking a look to uncover some of
the most surprising on-screen
relationships with huge age differences
you won't be able to watch these the
same way again
confessing that i love it in zendaya's
latest film
malcolm and marie she and co-star john
david washington have a large age
difference which
is actually a central part of their
relationship in the film
in reality the two do have 12 years
between them
zendaya being only 24 and washington 36.
you're angry no zendaya blew us away
when she was just 20 years old and
starring in the greatest showman
her romantic interest was played by the
always suave zac efron who was nine
years her senior at the time
it was quite the performance and efron
has even said that his kiss with zendaya
was
probably his favorite on-screen kiss
ever because of their character's
relationship and the build-up to that
moment
it's zendaya so ephron probably wasn't
exaggerating
when filming water for elephants robert
pattinson was
24 opposite the 34 year old reese
witherspoon
what makes this age difference
particularly weird is
the fact that a few years earlier
pattinson was playing witherspoon's son
in the film vanity
fair now that is awkward
i know who you are we loved never have i
ever
but we can't ignore the fact that darren
barnett doesn't look
like any high school boy we've ever
known that's because he was
28 when he filmed opposite maitreyi
ramakrishnan who was only 18 at the time
like ephron barnett was a fan of his
kiss with his younger co-star and said
it was one of his favorite scenes in the
show because
it was very raw and honest wow okay
it may be surprising to know that kj
apple was so much younger than his love
interest josie mccoy
played by ashley murray in riverdale the
two have a 10-year age gap between them
this is riverdale of course fans of
riverdale will know that there was a
pretty
obvious age gap between two characters
who shared a kiss on screen
kj apple was playing a high school
student and sarah habel
a high school teacher with about 20
years between them
their casting was pretty accurate but in
reality the two actually have a 15-year
age difference between them
sometimes that's all they are when
jennifer lawrence and chris pratt filmed
passengers together
they had an 11-year age difference
between them lawrence being 25 and pratt
36
there were actually rumors that the two
of them were having an affair while
filming
but this has been denied by both parties
but i would never see you again
11 years was a small gap for lawrence
since when she filmed silver lining's
playbook
co-star bradley cooper was 15 years
older than her
lawrence also faced rumors after this
film there were some whisperings that
the actors were dating
but cooper denied it and said it would
never happen since that's not the way
they saw each other
forget it one of the biggest age
differences we came across
was in the film third person between
liam neeson and olivia wilde
the two have a whopping 32-year age gap
neeson was no stranger to acting in love
opposite a younger actress
he did the same with january jones in
the film unknown with whom he shared a
25-year age gap
ironically when he was a younger actor
he was often paired with female love
interests who were much older than him
why then is he never here the romantic
scene between vanessa hudgens and james
franco in the film spring breakers was
super creepy as it is it's even more
cringe-worthy knowing that the two have
a 10-year age gap
hudgins was definitely successful in
shaking off her disney reputation after
this movie
unfortunately it wasn't the best
experience and hudgens had said that
she'd never wanted to do a scene like
the scandalous one she did with franco
and ashley benson
again while margot robbie gave an
incredible performance in the wolf of
wall street
we can't ignore the 16-year age gap
between herself and leonardo dicaprio
she was only 23 at the time while
dicaprio was 39.
oddly olivia wilde actually didn't get
cast in robbie's part because she came
across
too old even though she was still nine
years
younger than dicaprio hi naomi nice to
meet you
kieran knightley and johnny depp shared
a kiss when they did the pirates of the
caribbean
dead man's chest together and depp
expressed how awkward the experience was
for him
with 21 years between the two actors
depp felt their age difference made it
really uncomfortable fortunately nightly
said after the fact that it was actually
a very positive experience
what what since knightly had a 21-year
age difference with johnny depp
the eight-year gap between her and
orlando bloom probably didn't seem too
big
when filming the pirates of the
caribbean the curse of the black pearl
bloom was 25 and nightly was just 17.
unfortunately not everyone was a fan of
the pairing since there were criticisms
that the two didn't have enough
chemistry together on screen
but i do owe you thanks jack you do the
tv series carnival row
sees yet another kiss between co-stars
with a large age gap
in the case of orlando bloom and cara de
levine it's 15 years
bloom has said that the biggest
difference he notices between them is
how important instagram is as a tool for
delevine meanwhile
he's just learning the ropes what's your
name
filler when shay mitchell and sasha
peterson filmed their first kiss
together on pretty little liars
mitchell was 21 and peter so was only 13
years old
mitchell admitted she felt awkward and
uncomfortable kissing peterson because
she was so much younger
you make the world a better place it's
always awkward when one of the actors in
a romantic couple is still in their
teens
in the case of everything sucks it was
the six year age gap between actors
sydney sweeney and payton kennedy
kennedy was only 14 at the time
i don't really know right now most woody
allen films have men who are much
much older than their female co-stars
and a rational man
was no exception emma stone who was 27
at the time played opposite joaquin
phoenix who was 41.
the two played professor and student in
the film so the creep factor was
definitely present woody allen struck
again with his film magic in the
moonlight
this movie saw a 28-year age gap between
actors emma stone and colin firth
firth recognized how much older he was
and said he thought he'd seem old and
washed up alongside stone
hillary duff was only 15 when she played
opposite a 22 year old chad michael
murray in a cinderella story
duff confessed she had a really big
crush on murray and was nervous to
perform the romantic scenes with him
fortunately they became good friends
making the experience
easier sorry waited for the rain when
mila kunis auditioned for that 70s show
she actually lied about her age
pretending she was older so that she
could be cast
ashton kutcher felt awkward about
kissing her because she was so much
younger than he was and she felt more
like a sister
ironically the two have now been married
for over five
years don't worry though they didn't
start dating until
long after the show we should consult
the world's highest authority and
relationships
cosmo we were so surprised by a lot of
these and can't believe how often these
major age differences are normalized
how would you feel having that big an
age gap with a romantic co-star
which on-screen couple ages surprised
you the most
let us know in the comments if you
enjoyed make sure you hit that like
button
and subscribe to our channel
you